there's something I want to say about
all this this conversation about race
it's at moments like these that it's
important to make something clear if we
want to build a successful movement for
positive populism one that bites the
failures of elitism and finally
prioritizes the interests of working
Americans we must draw a line between
populism and racism between populism and
xenophobia between populism and white
supremacy of course but also between
populism and white superiority which is
subtly different but equally
unacceptable populism is about lifting
up working people its central message is
power to the people
and that applies regardless of skin
color I am an immigrant here with
Hungarian roots and a British background
I happen to be white that doesn't make
me any better than an immigrant from
Guatemala or India or Vietnam the
important difference between me and many
other immigrants is not my skin color is
that I arrived here with connections and
resources so I've been given every
opportunity to live the American dream
populist want that for all Americans
wherever you came from and however long
you've been here the crucial word is
Americans the incredible and unique
thing about this country is that anyone
can become an American you can move to
Britain but you'll never be British not
really I can tell you for sure that an
immigrant to Hungary could spend a
lifetime there and never be a Hungarian
if you got a China do you think they'll
ever let you become Chinese come on but
America is different
precisely because America is founded on
an idea one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
and not rooted in a racial or ethnic
identity America is always changing but
still stays the same the land of the
free and the home of the brave and if
there comes a time when white people are
no longer the majority in America as
long as immigration is controlled and
not a free-for-all and as long as
immigration is accompanied by
integration so
everyone who's here signs up to
America's laws and values that is not
something to fear or fight the real
fight for populace is not white versus
brown or white versus black or white
versus whatever other color you want to
mention the right fight is against the
elitists in both parties and throughout
our ruling establishment who for decades
have stolen the American dream for
themselves as I explained in my new book
positive populism it's the fight for
better jobs and higher incomes good
schools and modern skills affordable
health care and decent housing strong
families and strong communities clean
accountable government and power back in
people's hands that is positive populism
tell me what you think that next Rev FNC
and that Steve Hilton eggs